à une réplique de gabin dans le cap sur
biffins en matière de monnaies l'état a
tous les droits le particulier aucun
[Musique]
cette réforme du franc cfa ne semble pas
faire l'unanimité sur le continent la
plus boisée nul bouclé sa propre monnaie
elle n'est pas l'un c'est la politique
qui va être au coeur du processus de
création monétaire parce que la monnaie
est un fait social total ce n'est pas
qu'on fait économique cette monnaie
cedeao tenue pour être un succès que
signent un véritable engagement des
états en termes de solidarité est ce que
la réforme du franc cfa va permettre de
couper ce cordon ombilical avec la
france il y a des gens qui sont dans la
défense d'un système qui a vécu c'est
sur le système de la françafrique avec
le français phare qui me semblait que le
dernier avatar de la colonisation
française en arc
[Musique]
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
elle a une en allemagne les premières
estimations donnent la victoire aux
sociaux-démocrates sont atteints général
du spd revendique la formation du
prochain gouvernement pour le
représentant de la cd ou la formation
d'anglais la merkel je cite les pertes
sont amers à la cdo et pour l'heure
deuxièmes avec 24% des votes selon des
estimations à la sortie des urnes à un
niveau historiquement bas pour les
conservateurs on fera le point en direct
dans un instant depuis berlin avec notre
envoyé spécial est grand reporter régis
de sony
c'est une première en europe en islande
des femmes d'en être majoritaire au
parlement elle les élections
législatives d'hier vous par ailleurs
confirmé la coalition gauche droite au
pouvoir depuis quatre ans mais sa chef
de file la première ministre catherine
jacob de tir n'est pas pour autant
certaine de conserver son poste
[Musique]
enfin la france va doubler les doses de
vaccin à destination des pays pauvres
elle va passer de 60 millions à 100 bon
dawes offerte une annonce des manuels
mâcon alors que les résultats du
dispositif kovacs ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux 6% de taxi mais
seulement en afrique l'om est ce que ne
cesse de dénoncer l'illégalité
vaccinale
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france et on commence
bien sûr avec les élections fédérales en
allemagne les premières tendances ce
soir c'est à suivre donc en direct avec
nos invités et notre envoyé spécial sur
place
[Musique]
qui pour succéder à angela merkel
chancelière depuis 16 années en
allemagne selon joe principal de ce
scrutin les bureaux de vote ont fermé il
y a près de deux heures maintenant il
semble bien que les sociaux démocrates
dispose d'une légère avance sur les
conservateurs selon des projections
basées sur de premiers résultats a
d'ailleurs le spd revendique la victoire
et de leur côté les conservateurs du cd
ou veulent former le prochain
gouvernement malgré leur recul
historique écoutez
je me réjouis de voir tant de gens ici
et je me réjouis naturellement du
résultat du vote des citoyennes et
citoyens de ce pays
ils ont décidé que le parti
social-démocrate s'envolerait vers les
hauteurs et c'est un grand succès
[Applaudissements]
alcock rennes c'est une course au coude
à coude cette soirée électorale est
exceptionnel nous n'avons pas encore de
résultats finaux certains pas de
chiffres certains mais nous sommes déjà
en mesure de le dire nous ne sommes pas
contents du résultat
cependant l'issue du vote n'est pas
encore clair ce sera une longue soirée
dans tous les cas le résultat du vote
mais l'allemagne l'union tous les partis
démocrates face à de grands défis
selon tous les pronostics
il pourra y avoir d'abord un
gouvernement de trois partenaires de
coalition l'union a reçu de ses
électrices et électeurs un mandat clair
une voie pour l'union c'est une voix
contre une coalition dirigée par la
gauche
est allé jeter mc hugh analyste fluo de
bundesliga entre tout de suite un autre
grand reporter sur plage régis le
sommier
bonsoir à régis alors les bureaux de
vote ils ont fermé à 18h et tout au long
de cette journée bien malin celui qui
pouvait dire qui du spd ou de la cd ou
se détacherait mais on vient d'entendre
les deux camps à l'instant les sociaux
démocrates qui se positionne bien pour
l'emporter même s'il faut rester encore
prudent dans l'attenté des chiffres
définitifs
oui tout à fait les deux camps sont
effectivement encore au coude à coude il
semble quand même que l'as vence du spd
soit environ d'un point et on sait aussi
qu'un certain nombre de votes par
correspondance ne sont pas n'ont pas
encore été comptabilisés et il aurait
tendance probablement à accentuer
l'avancé de olaf scholz donc on est dans
une dynamique véritable pour le spd mais
on l'a vu la cdd ou à et par son son
leader armin laschet tu as s'est
positionné pour former le prochain
gouvernement va-t-on revenir à la grande
alliance qu'on avait souvent guélat
merkel mais ça avec l'inversion
justement des rapports entre le spd et
la cdu ou ce qui du fait pourrait
évincer les verts qui était un petit peu
les ce qu'on attendait dans ce dans ce
scrutin et qui finalement ont fait un
score moins élevé que celui qui était
prévu on les a estimés autour de 15 16
ils sont en dessous de 15 donc il ya eu
des surprises mais ce qu'on peut noter
c'est qu'il s'agit véritablement d'une
année d'une allemagne quand même
morceler les tractations vont durer très
longtemps on sait qu'on a l'habitude de
ces travaux de ces longues tractations
et donc du coup anglais la merkel
pourrait rester au pouvoir pendant
encore quelques mois ça pourrait aussi
conduire à une paralysie au niveau de
l'europe s'il est assis le chancelier
n'est pas désignée suffisamment
rapidement donc on est dans une ue part
d'incertitude sur comment va se se
former cette coalition sera t-elle une
coalition dans laquelle il y aura
justement trois parties la cd ou et le
spd est ce qu'ils vont s'entendre ou
finalement est-ce que le spd va décider
peut-être de faire une alliance avec les
libéraux démocrates et les verts est-ce
que c'est à lyon cela lui donnera plus
de 50% tout ça ça va être les
tractations une mathématique une
arithmétique très complexe très propres
à l'allemagne et qui peut durer des
semaines alors un mot et fille sur les
électeurs 60 millions d'électeurs
étaient appelés aux urnes les électeurs
allemands indécis vous l'avez dit tout
au long de cette journée finalement
comme si ce n'était pas si facile de
tourner la page de ses années avec
angela merkel au pouvoir
on a senti le l'ombre gigantesque dans
gala merkel sur ce scrutin peser sur le
scrutin elle était partout on l'a vu m
voilà ce candidat olaf scharf reprendre
la fiole ce pardon reprendre le logo le
losange les mains dans gala merkel sur
la poitrine qui était un peu sa marque
de fabrique et puis on sentait vraiment
même chez la candidate des verts
n'allait n'aborde bob barbeuk pardon on
sentait vraiment qu'il y avait une
volonté de s'inscrire dans la trace dans
gala merkel parce que cet héritage il
est effectivement immense et il est
celui d'une d'une allemagne stable les
allemands non le principal est la
principale préoccupation des allemands
c'est de conserver de cette stabilité
alors on a parlé de renouveau on a vu
effectivement ce nouveau visage de cette
leader des verts mais ça n'a pas suffi
visage visiblement à faire cette percée
espérée à propros conduire une nouvelle
femme à la tête de l'allemagne donc ça
va être encore très incertain à la
manière des électeurs allemands
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de partis
qui sont à plus de 10% c'est
exceptionnel quand angela merkel il y à
16 ans avait pris le pouvoir et bien il
faut se rappeler que la cd ou et le spd
tous les deux faisait plus de 70% des
électeurs aujourd'hui on le voit même
s'il s'allie il peine à dépasser les 50%
merci à vous régis le sommier on entendu
armin à la chatte la soirée promet
d'être long on va vous retrouver tout à
leur merci également à alexandre
planasse qui vous accompagne à la caméra
et on va retrouver tout de suite michel
carbou chic et ancien député européen
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce soir semble défense pour
commenter ces premiers résultats issus
des urnes à l'issue de ces élections au
fédéral en allemagne selon donc les
sondages une légère avance pour le spd
et son candidat olaf scholz a devant la
cedh et oud armée de lâches est le
candidat dans google à merkel est ce que
vous croyez que l'allemagne à mort cela
un renouveau dans tous les cas on
s'apprête réellement à tourner la page
mercal mais écoutez suivant les chiffres
que vous indiquez on se prépare à deux
scénarios soit le scénario classique
c'est-à-dire la continuation de de ce
que nous avons vécu depuis un certain
nombre d'années à savoir une coalition
spd csu
cd ou
alors avec monsieur harvey nash calciné
gars s'il est à égalité avec le spd
soit soit monsieur olaf scholz à 1 2
points d'avance et à touche touche tu
avec les avec la cd ou et à ce moment là
on peut avoir donc là même la même
configuration avec laquelle nous avons
vécu depuis depuis pas mal d'années soit
ce que je crois monsieur olaf scholz
décide de faire une alliance avec les
libéraux avec les verts à ce moment là
suivant les chiffres que vous indiquez
il sera à plus de 50% de des électeurs
qui ont voté 50 52 % et donc qu'il peut
il peut choisir cela rien cela il sera
le prochain chancelier ce qui veut dire
une alternance alors en allemagne se
sont pas des alternances politiques très
forte puisque monsieur sol c'était déjà
dans la coalition qui a gouverné
l'allemagne depuis un certain temps
donc il s'entraîne en parlera pas de
grandes ruptures peut-être sera-t-il un
peu plus non pas européens puisqu'ils
sont tous européens mais il sera
peut-être un peu plus enclins à une
europe de la défense que les
conservateurs
sera peut-être plus enclins
à parler avec monsieur poutine
ce que madame merkel récemment a tenté
de faire sans grand succès
voilà les interrogations qu'on peut
avoir mais c'est soit la continuation du
même système de coalition soit une
alternance politique alors puisque vous
parlez de leur pensée qu'angela merkel
c'est une européenne convaincue
beaucoup d'allemands lui ont d'ailleurs
reproché un parfois de privilégier
l'europe au détriment de l'allemagne est
ce qu'à ce niveau là justement il ya un
changement de paradigme auquel il faut
s'attendre vous pensez que les
sociaux-démocrates vous venez d'évoquer
vont aller encore plus loin donc c'est
que monsieur scholz a été reçue
récemment par le président macron et qu'
ils sont ils sont très compatibles s'est
très bien entendu avec lui et je crois
que de toute façon l'allemagne et la
france ont condamné à continuer le
chemin qu'elle empruntait déjà depuis
depuis six décennies à c'est-à-dire la
la la route ensemble parce que l'europe
n'a pas d'autre issue que l' axe paris
berlin et l'axé paris-berlin face à ce
qui vient de se passer en afghanistan ce
qui vient de se passer avec la faire des
sous marins ce que de noms connus avec
la syrie ce que nous avons connu avec la
turquie en méditerranée
lacs sont co allemand doit s'imposer de
plus en plus fort c'est à dire la
puissance militaire française et la
puissance économique allemand c'est ce
duo là qui fait avancer l'europe csu du
aulas qui va construire prochainement
sous la présidence française de monsieur
macron à partir de janvier 2022 je pense
l'europe puissance leur puissance à vous
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire une
europe de la défense et quand on parle
de l'europe de la défense et pas
seulement on pouvoir projeter une une
opération militaire à l'extérieur de
l'europe c'est aussi faire le rang
militaire industriel parce que tant que
nous serons pardonnez-moi mais cette
avance qui met vous évoquez la faire à
des sous marins ça montre quand même que
cet axe dont vous parlez un paris berlin
finalement ça semble pas peser très
lourd sur la scène internationale non
mais ça pèse ce que pèse l'union
européenne aujourd'hui sur la scène
interne sonal c'est à dire nous sommes
devenus une puissance économique grâce à
l'euro qui vous rappelle et la deuxième
monnaie de réserve et de change
mondiales mais nous ne sommes pas encore
une puissance au sens politique où on
l'entend et je suis heureux que
récemment madame van der linden la
présidente de la commission européenne
afin discours remarqué devant les
députés européens à strasbourg en
session en en mettant l'accent sur
l'europe de la défense ça veut dire que
chacun a conscience que nous ne pouvons
plus compter sur les américains et que
nous devons enfin être nous mêmes
enfin être nous mêmes c'est assurer nous
mêmes notre propre défense notre
capacité militaire est avec l'allemagne
nous avons besoin avec l'allemagne
d'allemagne et d'autres alliés ont parlé
avec monsieur erdogan pour parler du
caucase on parlait de la méditerranée
elle est notre allié pour avec monsieur
poutine elle est essentielle essentiel
pour continuer à développer le rang et
je pense que dans les prochains mois
nous allons avoir des avancées très
significatives
vous avez que ce soit avec monsieur sol
ce que je sois encore avec madame merkel
qui restent encore pouvoir quelques mois
s'il n'ya mésentente pour former une
coalition pour terminer vous aviez
évoqué tout à l'heure les ailes et les
scénarios concernant la future coalition
allemande que dire sur la sd le parti
d'extrême droite allemand est ce que
cette élection va confirmer un
enracinement dans le paysage politique
allemand vous pensez parle apparemment
oui c'est à dire que ils sont annie %
eux sont à 10 % et le front national le
rassemblement national enfance et à 20%
donc on n'a pas de leçon à leurs données
en la matière c'est une réalité
européenne les populismes et les
développements d'extrême droite c'est
une réalité de l'europe que nous vivons
depuis maintenant une quinzaine d'années
donc je pense que ce qu'on pensait
qu'ils ont un score peut-être supérieur
rappelez vous il ya deux ans le fbi
était été été revendiquée dans un
certain nombre de länder de former des
coalitions avec les conservateurs et
apparemment ils ont le score qui n'est
pas terrible l'extrême gauche enfin la
gauche la gauche dure allemande est à 5%
et l'extrême droite allemande et à 10%
merci merci beaucoup à vous à michel
sicard bon si je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien député européen merci pour cet
éclairage
après 16 ans demande à la chancelière
allemande vit donc ses derniers instants
à la tête du gouvernement avec son
départ le pays amorce une nouvelle page
de son histoire politique on voit cela
avec l alma scalliet
bruxelles face à la peur du vide avec le
départ dans gala merkel l'europe perd un
gage de stabilité c'est ans durant la
chancelière a joué un rôle crucial au
sein de l'union européenne
continuité et fermeté la dirigeante qui
a grandi en ex rda avait à coeur de
maintenir l'unité du bloc européen de la
crise de la zone euro il ya dix ans en
passant par l'afflux de migrants 2015
jusqu'au référendum sur le brésil en
2016 et plus récemment la pandémie de
covile 19 angela merkel avec son art du
compromis a su mener la barque
européenne ces derniers mois les
dirigeants de l'ue eux ont multiplié les
hommages à celle que l'on surnomme
moutier
ne sont devenus anguila merkel était et
est toujours le leader incontesté de
l'europe
elle était l'une des rares personnes à
pouvoir prendre le téléphone et appeler
n'importe lequel d'entre nous
et à pouvoir influencer les événements
dans la région
[Musique]
elle apporte raison et des sens à la
politique quand elle commence à parler
au conseil européen beaucoup de gens
regardent encore leur iphone mais
ensuite il arrange tous leur iphone les
stylos sont posées et nous l'écoutons
elle a une autorité énorme elle s'est
toujours replacer les choses dans leur
contexte y compris les nombreuses années
passées en europe qu'elle a contribué à
façonner souvent lorsque nous sommes
dans une impasse elle lance une idée et
nous repartons de l'avant cela va nous
manquer fermeté pour certains rigidité
pour d'autres lieux est en moins bon
état que lors de l'arrivée au pouvoir de
merkel en 2005 c'est ce qu' a commenté
le magazine der spiegel pointant le
manque de vision de la chancelière le
fossé sur les questions financières
entre le nord et le sud le breakbeat ou
encore la montée des démocraties
libérales on se souvient aussi d'une
époque au tournant des années 2010 quand
la grèce menaçait de faire faillite ou
l'obsession allemande pour l'austérité
avait profondément divisé l'europe
merkel a enterré l'idée des euro
obligations et a refermé le cercueil mal
à merkel est donc resté fidèle à
elle-même mais d'une manière qui est
extraordinairement négative et
destructrice pour lieu la chancelière
laisse à son successeur des chantiers de
taille lieu est confrontée à des défis
historiques
reconstruire une économie forte après la
pandémie lutter contre le changement
climatique
affirmer son rôle géopolitique face aux
états unis et à la chine
si les européens attendent de
l'allemagne qu'elle continue à faire
preuve de leadership au sein de lieux
d'autres lorgnent cette place de premier
de la classe parmi eux l'italie porté
par mario draghi avides de jouer un plus
grand rôle sur le vieux continent sans
oublier la france qui prendra la
présidence tournante de l'ue eux au
début de l'année prochaine
et ce départ d'angola merkel est ce
qu'il pourrait changer les relations
entre l'allemagne et la russie pas
vraiment au beau fixe éléments de
réponse avec notre correspondante à
moscou vera goffman
maintenir le dialogue malgré les
divergences étaient le modus operandi de
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
dans ses relations avec la russie
et même si nous avons de profondes
divergences aujourd'hui nous nous
parlons et il faut que cela continue
afin de mettre de l'ordre dans les
relations germano russes et les
perfectionner lors de son dernier
tête-à-tête en forme d'adieu avec alain
moscou vladimir poutine a reconnu que
c'était en partie grâce à un glas merkel
que l'allemagne était considéré comme un
des partenaire clé de la russie je tiens
à souligner que la république fédérale
d'allemagne reste l'un de nos principaux
partenaires tant en europe que dans le
monde en général et ce notamment grâce
aux efforts que vous avez déployés au
cours des 16 dernières années en tant
que chancelière fédérale des divergences
et des crises il y en a eu pas mal
durant les six années de marquer le
pouvoir des accusations d'ingérence dans
les élections allemandes ou de cyber
espionnage sans oublier la sphère
navalni qui malgré sa résonance extrême
n'a pas ébranlé la construction du
gazoduc nord stream 2 décidément au
projet unique que ni l'administration
trope ni l'administration baden n'ont su
faire capoter
je crois qu'à berlin il savait et savent
très bien sûr que les relations avec la
russie sont d'une importance
fondamentale et si l'allemagne s'étaient
pliés dans cette situation avec nord
stream 2 en autorisant une ingérence
dans les accords économiques bilatéraux
sous l'influencé de l'intervention d'un
pays tiers alors elle aurait démontré sa
faiblesse devant son propre peuple et ça
ne va pas et c'est la première chose
deuxièmement nous savons que pour le
secteur industriel allemande sur lui
dont les dépenses énergétiques sont déjà
les plus élevés parmi les pays
occidentaux la sécurité énergétique des
sources d'approvisionnement est au moins
primordiale car son avenir en dépend en
principe
avec les élections d'estag les relations
russo allemandes risquent de prendre un
tour nouveau
trois candidats sont donnés favoris pour
remplacer angela merkel au poste de
chancelière la candidate des verts à
nallet naber box et non seulement
prononcé contre le projet nord stream 2
au point d'envisager renoncer mais a
aussi promis de durcir
le ton dans ses relations avec moscou ce
gazoduc contredit les intérêts
géostratégiques des européens il est
clairement dirigé contre l'ukraine il
entre en contradiction avec les
objectifs climatiques européen et toutes
les sanctions de l'union européenne
contre la russie c'est donc un projet
absolument nuisibles de son côté le
candidat de l'union
chrétien-démocrate armes ils l'achètent
que le journal süddeutsche zeitung a
qualifié de celui qui comprend poutine
d'air poutine faire stern a déclaré que
l'allemagne pourrait arrêter d'acheminer
du gaz russe via north stream 2 si
moscou ne respectait pas les conditions
de l'accord ou l'utiliser pour faire
pression sur l'ukraine pas évident dans
le contexte actuel de risque de pénurie
d'hydrocarbures en europe même dans la
plus froide des guerre froide il ya
toujours eu des échanges économiques et
un dialogue entre les sociétés civiles
cela doit être notre principe tout en
exhortant au respect des droits humains
le troisième candidat on lève chaque
membre du parti social démocrate qui se
positionne comme l'héritier de merkel
mise sur un dialogue avec moscou même
s'il a dénoncé le rattachement de la
crimée à la russie en 2014 critiquer la
situation autour des droits de l'homme
dans le pays où l'empoisonnement présumé
de l'opposant alexeï navalni je soutiens
l'idée selon laquelle la russie et
d'autres pays doivent accepter la
poursuite de l'intégration européenne
nous ne voulons pas revenir à la
politique des 17ème 18ème et 19ème
siècle lorsque les grandes puissances
mondiales russie allemagne france
angleterre faisait de la politique les
uns avec les autres si nous voulons
assurer la sécurité commune en europe
l'union européenne et la russie
devraient s'y engager
une page se tourne donc dans les
relations russo allemandes avec le
départ d'angela merkel reste à savoir
quelle sera la tonalité que le nouveau
chancelier ou la nouvelle chancelière
donnera au prochain chapitre
autres élections législatives en islande
cette fois le gouvernement de coalition
gauche droite va conserver sa majorité
avec 37 des 63 sièges du parlement
islandais soit trois députés de plus
qu'auparavant on ne va donc pas assisté
à un scénario de blocage politique ce
que laissait redouter lé sondage un
soulagement pour catherine jacob de tir
la première ministre même si son parti
gauche vert perd quelques des sièges on
l'écouté
il ya une atmosphère merveilleuse qui
règne dans ce parti comme vous pouvez le
constatez donc je pense que ce sera une
belle soirée mais je sais que les
résultats seront compliqués il sera
compliqué de former un nouveau
gouvernement nous allons d'abord
réfléchir à nos résultats et ensuite
évaluer ce qui va se passer il ya
beaucoup de choses auxquelles il faut
penser avant de former un nouveau
gouvernement nous devrons voir comment
les partis gouvernementaux s'en sortent
ensemble et comment nous nous en sortons
d'après ces résultats préliminaires nous
perdons un peu et les progressistes
montrent
[Musique]
la majorité sortante au pouvoir depuis
quatre ans est donc reconduite une
surprise néanmoins la montée en
puissance à des femmes à l'assemblée où
elles deviennent désormais à majoritaire
on voit cela avec yves olivier b
c'est probablement le nombre à retenir
de cette soirée électorale en islande
trente trois comme le nombre de sièges
qui seront désormais occupés par des
femmes sur les 63 que contre l'al qingli
le parlement islandais une première dans
ce pays et en europe l'islande dépassant
désormais la suède qui était jusque là
le pays le plus proche de la parité au
sein de son assemblée avec une présence
féminine à hauteur de 47% à l'échelle
mondiale la terre de glace forte de ses
52 3% de femmes parlementaires restent
encore loin du rwanda premiers de ce
classement paritaire qui affiche un
score supérieur à 61 % d'islande
pionnière en la matière d'égalité femmes
hommes ce n'est pas une situation
inédite en témoigne la grande grève
féminine d'octobre 1975 pour réclamer de
meilleurs salaires ou encore l'élection
de vie glisse film bogado tir en 1981
première femme élue démocratiquement
présidente de la république dans le
monde aujourd'hui le pays en tête sur
les questions d'égalité salariale depuis
12 ans vient donc de renouveler sa
confiance à l'alliance gauche droite
sortante mais sa chef de file catherine
jakobsdottir n'est pourtant pas assuré
de rester première ministre dix mille
500 visas de travail provisoire vont
être délivrés au royaume uni une mesure
prise par le gouvernement pour faire
face à une pénurie de main d'oeuvre pour
certains médias britanniques il y a deux
causes à ce phénomène la pandémie est
une législation migratoire post break
site plus strictes à les précisions de
grégoire de 6 elle ne plus dépendre
d'une main d'oeuvre étrangère
c'est l'un des credo de la politique
migratoire post break site du
gouvernement de boris johnson fermer le
robinet de la main d'oeuvre étrangère
peut qualifier les mots de la ministre
de l'intérieur britannique début 2020
était clair seulement cette orientation
mêlée à la pandémie semble provoquer des
manques criants de travailleurs dans
certains secteurs notamment le transport
de marchandises la carence de chauffeur
poids lourds engendre depuis quelques
jours des files d'attentes interminables
à l'entrée des stations essence
c'est un peu embarrassant c'est
embarrassant cela donne une impression
comme si nous vivions dans un pays du
tiers monde
il parlait d'une pénurie de chauffeurs
ou quelque chose comme ça mais je suis
vraiment désespérée et je ne sais pas où
aller ensuite
tout cela remonte aux briques site
depuis le brésil pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans toutes les industries si
cela aurait dû être pensé mais ce
gouvernement n'a jamais pensé à l'avenir
et ils se contentent de réagir un
problème au lieu de réfléchir à ce que
sont les problèmes et d'essayer de
penser à une solution face à cette
urgence le gouvernement prévoit de
délivrer jusqu'à 5000 visas temporaires
pour recruter des chauffeurs mais cela
pourrait être insuffisant pour pallier
un manque de 100000 routier d'après les
estimations de la chaîne sky news
l'appel de l'exécutif à ne pas se
précipiter dans les stations essence
n'est que partiellement respectée et
outre cette pénurie de carburant les
britanniques font également face ces
dernières semaines à des ruptures de
stocks de produits alimentaires dans les
rayons des supermarchés pour des causes
similaires une réelle problématique dans
un pays qui importe 80 % de la
nourriture qu'ils consomment
la france va doubler le nombre de
vaccins donnés aux pays pauvres et une
annoncé hier de manuel macro à
l'occasion du concert caritatif global
cities and le nombre de doses légué
passe donc de 60 à 120 millions à
destination des pays africains qui peine
à vacciner leur population lors de la
66e assemblée générale de l'onu le
président sud africain a d'ailleurs
accusé les pays riches de s'approprier
la majorité des doses de vaccin et
pourtant malgré cette pénurie l'afrique
du sud s'organise en coin cela vexe
bastien abat
ce train qui traverse les régions les
plus reculées d'afrique du sud ne
transporte pas de voyageurs c'est en
fait un centre de vaccination ambulants
affrété spécialement par la société
étatique transnet il va à la rencontre
de la population non vaccinée
baptisé trans bas qu il permet un effort
supplémentaire dans la lutte contre le
coc vie de 19 dans un pays qui déplore
déjà plus de 80 mille décès
et stocker le train va rester dans la
province du cap oriental durant 14
semaines nous allons nous arrêter dans
cette gare dans chacune desquelles nous
resterons deux semaines pour vacciner la
population
actuellement nous finissons à soit pop
et nous allons nous diriger vers east
london pied au mont route à ce jour nous
avons vacciné juste un petit peu moins
de mille patients chasse
le gouvernement sud africain accuse un
retard colossal dans la lutte contre le
coc vite 19 la faute entre autres à une
campagne de vaccination laborieuse et à
des habitants réticents ce centre de
vaccination mobile permet de
sensibiliser la population désormais
soulagé d'être vacciné
je suis heureuse et me sens sereine au
moins je sais que je suis protégé tout
comme mes enfants et mon entourage je
suis donc vraiment sereine maintenant
que c'est fait j'attendais ce moment où
je pourrais moi aussi dire que je fais
partie des personnes vaccinées en
afrique du sud
le pays a été le premier du continent à
produire des doses de vaccin sur son sol
avant cela le gouvernement a dû
batailler contre des retards de
livraison accusant les laboratoires de
favoriser les pays les plus riches au
détriment des autres des semaines
d'actes man tu le fait que plus de 82%
des doses de vaccins dans le monde et
été acquise par les pays riches alors
qu'au moins d'arbres s'en est allé aux
pays à faible revenu est une
condamnation de l'humanité
si nous ne nous attaquons pas d'urgence
à ce problème la pandémie il durera
beaucoup plus longtemps et de nouvelles
mutations du virus se répandront et
apparaîtront
au cours de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu de nombreux dirigeants ont appelé
à relancer la vaccination aux quatre
coins du monde pour parvenir à
l'objectif fixé avant la prochaine
session vacciner 70 % de la population
dans chaque pays le défis restent
énormes pour l'afrique du sud dont
seulement 14 % de la population ont été
vaccinés
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans une trentaine à 20minutes rester
avec nous sur arte france
et
[Musique]
pour
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission de débat qui décrypte chaque
semaine l'actualité politique au
sommaire dans le viseur de jacques de
guillebon et d'alexis poulain la place
de la france dans le monde et au sein de
l'union européenne
l'humiliation liées à l'annulation du
contrat du siècle par l'australie la
crise diplomatique qui en découlent à
quelques mois du début de sa présidence
à la tête de l'europe c'est un revers de
taille pour la politique extérieure des
manuels macron la france est elle
toujours une puissance mondiale d'hôtel
renforcer sa place au sein de lieux où
ne compter que sur elle même c'est le
débat de la semaine
alexis poulin et jacques de guillebon
s'attaquent ensuite aux primaires des
partis politiques alors que les
sympathisants écologistes ont emmené
l'inattendu sandrine rousseau au second
tour de leurs primaires